I want to start off our discussion,
with a little exercise where we try to
find an upper bound on
the value of a linear program.
We'll start with this one here, and
we're going to take a linear combination
of these inequality constraints,
to obtain an upper bound
on the objective function.
Multiplying the first inequality by y1,
and the second by y2.
And adding them together gives
us this inequality here.
Where I have collected terms.
Note that it's important
that the y's be non-negative
to avoid reversing the inequalities.
Note that if we choose y1, and
y2 such that 2 y1- y2 is at least 6.
And also that, y1 + 2 y2, is at least
negative 2, well then this becomes,
an upper bound on the objective
function, for our linear program.
And for the exercise,
I want you to choose y1 and
y2, to make this bound
as tight as possible.